Oh come all ye faithful, joyful, and triumphant, and let us have, for once, a rational, adult conversation about Santa Claus. You're listening to a special Christmas edition of This American Life from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
各位虔诚、快乐、凯旋的朋友们，过来过来，让我们破天荒地针对圣诞老人进行一次理性的、成年人的对话。您正在收听的是由芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《美国生活》圣诞特别节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
And let us head back my friend, back for a moment before Christmas lights were invented, back before Macy's department store goes up on 34th Street, back before the moment Charles Dickens writes A Christmas Carol, back, my friend, to the molten lava core at the very center of modern Christmas, the day that someone first believed in Santa Claus. Someone has actually figured out when this happened. And it's in 1822, in America, in New York City.
让我们回到我的朋友，回到圣诞彩灯发明之前，回到梅西百货在第34街开业之前，回到查尔斯·狄更斯写下《圣诞颂歌》之前，回到现代圣诞节最核心的熔岩地带，回到某个人第一次相信圣诞老人的那一刻。有人确实搞清楚了这件事发生的时间。是在1822年，在美国，在纽约市。
And who do we have to thank for the whole thing? A bunch of rich guys. And not just any rich guys. Aristocratic rich guys who all agreed that there were big, big problems with the entire American experiment, then very young, then more young to them than the Star Wars trilogy is to us. And these guys did not like it one little bit. They were very suspicious of democracy, modern capitalism, Thomas Jefferson.
我们要感谢谁促成了这一切？一群富人。不仅仅是普通的富人，而是贵族富人。他们一致认为，当时非常年轻的美国实验存在巨大的问题，对他们而言，美国比《星球大战》三部曲对我们而言还要年轻。这些人一点也不喜欢它。他们对民主、现代资本主义和托马斯·杰斐逊非常怀疑。
They just saw it as chaos, and as a takeover of the city, and, really, the whole country, by the mob.
他们只是将其视为混乱，视为暴民对城市，乃至整个国家的接管。
This is Stephen Nissenbaum, who has written a history about all of this called The Battle for Christmas.
这是史蒂芬·尼森鲍姆，他写了一本关于这一切的历史书，名为《圣诞之战》。
Ordinary people, by which they really meant the middle classes, were taking over the city commercially and politically. They called these people the mob.
普通人，他们实际上指的是中产阶级，正在商业和政治上接管这座城市。他们称这些人为暴民。
Now one of the dreadful areas of mob rule, from their point of view, was what happened at Christmas every year. There was all this public rowdiness at Christmas. It was celebrated the way we celebrate New Year's Eve now.
在他们看来，暴民统治的可怕领域之一就是每年圣诞节发生的事情。圣诞节有各种公共吵闹行为。那时人们庆祝圣诞节的方式就像我们现在庆祝新年前夜一样。
Yes, exactly. If you were worried about the mob, the one time of year when you probably had to be most on your guard was the Christmas season.
是的，没错。如果你担心暴民，那么一年中你最需要防备的时候可能就是圣诞节期间。
During Christmas, roving bands of toughs went from door to door, demanding drinks and making threats. There was riotous noise-making, massive public drunkenness. You can understand why these rich guys just hated it.
在圣诞节期间，成群结队的暴徒挨家挨户地索要酒水并进行威胁。到处都是喧闹的噪声和大规模的公共酗酒。你可以理解为什么这些富人如此憎恨它。
And so they set out to create new traditions, traditions that they hoped might replace all this debauchery. Starting around 1810, they tried to convince people that a certain fourth century Catholic saint, Saint Nicholas-- you may recognize the name-- was, in fact, the patron saint of New York. For about a decade after that, they tried to make his saint's day, which is December 6, into a regular December holiday on the island of Manhattan.
于是他们着手创造新的传统，希望这些传统能取代所有这些颓废行为。大约从1810年开始，他们试图说服人们，一位四世纪的天主教圣徒——圣尼古拉（你可能认出这个名字）——实际上是纽约的守护神。在那之后的十年里，他们试图将他的圣人纪念日，也就是12月6日，变成曼哈顿岛上一个常规的12月节日。
Now these guys were very serious about the whole business of creating new holidays for the new nation. At least one of them was involved in the creation of Washington's birthday, Columbus Day, and the Fourth of July. But this Saint Nicholas thing, it was just not catching on. And if you saw the way that they portrayed Saint Nicholas in a handout that one of these guys had printed in 1810, you might see why.
这些人对为新国家创造新节日这件事非常认真。他们中至少有一人参与了华盛顿生日、哥伦布日和7月4日独立日的创立。但是这个圣尼古拉的事情，就是流行不起来。如果你看到他们在1810年印制的一份传单中描绘圣尼古拉的方式，你可能就会明白原因。
That picture doesn't look at all like the modern Christmas Santa Claus that we know. In fact, he's a very dignified, magisterial bishop.
那张照片看起来一点也不像我们今天所知的现代圣诞老人。事实上，他是一位非常庄严、威严的主教。
He's in clerical robes.
他穿着教士长袍。
He's in clerical robes. He has a bishop's mitre and sceptre, a cross. Everything about him looks like one of those medieval saints.
他穿着教士长袍。他戴着主教法冠，拿着权杖，还有一个十字架。他的一切看起来都像那些中世纪的圣徒。
He has a halo.
他带着光环。
He has a halo around him. That Saint Nicholas comes to punish every bit as much as he does to reward.
他周围带着光环。那位圣尼古拉既会惩罚人，也会奖励人。
Saint Nicholas appears in a book in 1809 and a couple of poems over the next few years. It is not until 1821 that somebody mentions him arriving on Christmas Eve or describes him in a sleigh pulled by a reindeer, one reindeer in this case. And then in 1822, one of these rich guys, a man named Clement Clarke Moore, changes everything when he writes a poem. How often do you ever get to say that? He changes everything when he writes a poem.
圣尼古拉在1809年的一本书和此后几年的几首诗中出现。直到1821年，才有人提到他在平安夜到来，或者描述他坐在由驯鹿（在这种情况下是一只）拉着的雪橇里。然后在1822年，这些富人中的一位，一个名叫克莱门特·克拉克·摩尔的人，写了一首诗，改变了一切。你有多常有机会说出这句话？他写了一首诗，改变了一切。
This is the poem that begins, "Twas the night before Christmas when all through the house, not a creature was stirring, not even a mouse."
这首诗的开头是：“圣诞前夜，万家寂静，毫无声息，连老鼠也不动。”
I actually find it kind of incredible in reading this history a century and a half later that the poem that actually created Santa Claus is one that is still around.
在一个半世纪后阅读这段历史，我实际上觉得创造圣诞老人的那首诗至今仍在流传真是令人难以置信。
Yeah. But what he did was he transformed Saint Nicholas utterly. No longer in this poem is Saint Nicholas a dignified bishop. In fact, there's nothing bishop-like about him. He's short. He smiles. He's fat. A guy who just loves kids.
是的。但他所做的是彻底改变了圣尼古拉。在这首诗中，圣尼古拉不再是一位庄严的主教。事实上，他一点也不像主教。他个子矮小，面带微笑，身体发胖。一个非常喜爱孩子的人。
It's all there in the poem, the stockings hung with care, the reindeers' names, the fact that he comes down the chimney. And note Santa's clothes the next time that you hear the poem, a fur coat, a short pipe, a bag that he carries over his shoulder, like an ordinary Yankee trader, not a bishop. This was the key to the whole thing, Nissenbaum says.
诗中一切都有了：精心悬挂的长筒袜，驯鹿的名字，他从烟囱下来的事实。下次当你听到这首诗时，注意一下圣诞老人的衣服：皮大衣、短烟斗、背在肩上的袋子，就像一个普通的美国商人，而不是主教。尼森鲍姆说，这就是整件事的关键。
This takes him out of the aristocracy and makes him a regular working man. Middle class, even before there was a name for middle class. A perfect hero for the new nation. And Clement Clarke Moore didn't have any idea how popular his vision of Santa might get. And so, incredibly, he didn't publish the poem. He just passed it around to a few friends.
这使他脱离了贵族阶层，成为一个普通的劳动者。在中产阶级还没有名字之前，他就是中产阶级。他是新国家完美的英雄。而克莱门特·克拉克·摩尔根本不知道他的圣诞老人形象会变得多么受欢迎。因此，令人难以置信的是，他并没有发表这首诗。他只是把它传给了几个朋友。
If he had wanted this to become the American ritual, he probably would have taken steps to publish it. But he didn't. The story has it that a niece of his took it upon herself to publish it the following year in a newspaper in the Hudson River town of Troy.
如果他想让这成为美国的一种仪式，他可能会采取措施去发表它。但他没有。据故事说，他的一个侄女自作主张在第二年将其发表在哈德逊河畔特洛伊镇的一份报纸上。
And it was republished, and republished after that. And within a few decades, the Christmas described in the poem, a Christmas spent at home, with Santa bringing toys and kids with parents all indoors, that Christmas replaced the big, drunken, loud, carousing out on the street kind of Christmas. So the aristocrats got their way. They killed the noisy version of Christmas, though accidentally.
后来它被反复转载。几十年内，诗中描述的圣诞节——一家人待在家里，圣诞老人送来礼物，孩子和父母都在室内——取代了那种在大街上醉酒、吵闹、狂欢的圣诞节。所以贵族们如愿以偿了。他们扼杀了吵闹版的圣诞节，尽管是偶然的。
Well, today on our program, we bring you stories about Santa and the many, many ways in which he is seen. Act One, The Red Velvet Underground, in which one brave man heads out into the desert to wrestle with a devil named Claus. Act Two, If This Sleigh is A-Rockin', Don't Come A-Knockin', in which Sarah Vowell explains why so many pop songs show Santa getting all jiggy. Act Three, It Takes a Nation of Santas to Hold Us Back, a story of two little boys and a man that they hope at least has some pull with Santa. Act Four, Santa in Handcuffs, Prometheus in Chains, in which we are proud to present an all-new story of The Most Fantastic Crimefighter The World Has Ever Known, who single-handedly heads from department store to department store to stop a red and white menace. Act Five, Santa Versus the Easter Bunny, in which writer David Sedaris tries to promote cross-cultural understanding-- so badly needed everywhere these days, my friend-- for the holiday season. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的节目中，我们将为您带来关于圣诞老人的故事，以及看待他的许多种方式。第一幕，《红色天鹅绒地下》，一位勇敢的人走进沙漠，去与一个名叫克劳斯的恶魔搏斗。第二幕，《如果这雪橇在摇晃，别来敲门》，萨拉·沃威尔解释了为什么这么多流行歌曲表现圣诞老人表现得如此轻浮。第三幕，《我们需要一个圣诞老人国家来阻挡我们》，两个小男孩和一个他们希望在圣诞老人面前能说得上话的男人的故事。第四幕，《戴手铐的圣诞老人，锁链中的普罗米修斯》，我们很自豪地呈现一个关于世界上有史以来最出色的犯罪斗士的全新故事，他单枪匹马从一家百货公司走到另一家百货公司，阻止一场红白色的灾难。第五幕，《圣诞老人大战复活节兔子》，作家大卫·塞达瑞斯试图促进跨文化理解——我亲爱的朋友，这在当今世界任何地方都非常迫切——为了这个节日。请继续收听。
Act One, The Red Velvet Underground. We begin our program today with a story with the most idealistic possible vision of Santa and a quest for something lost about Santa. From Mike Paterniti.
第一幕，《红色天鹅绒地下》。今天节目的开始是一个关于圣诞老人最理想主义的愿景，以及对圣诞老人某种失落之物的追求的故事。来自迈克·帕特尼蒂。
I guess I'd somehow become OK with the death of everything, the death of faith, honor, idealism. I thrived in the country club of the death of everything until a newspaper headline caught my eye, "Santa Faces the Sack." Bloomingdale's in Manhattan had fired its store Santa, and Macy's was adopting an interactive North Pole. Santa Claus was on the verge of extinction. I got thinking about that, and, I don't know, something in me kind of snapped. I can't recall the exact Christmas I parted ways with Santa, nor am I sure how I lost him.
我想我对自己成为万物凋零、信仰、荣誉、理想主义的终结者感到释然。我在万物凋零的乡村俱乐部里茁壮成长，直到一条报纸标题吸引了我的眼球：“圣诞老人面临被裁”。曼哈顿的布鲁明黛百货公司解雇了店里的圣诞老人，梅西百货正在采用一个互动式的北极。圣诞老人正处于灭绝的边缘。我开始思考这个问题，而且，不知道为什么，我内心深处的某种东西断了。我不记得我是哪一年与圣诞老人分道扬镳的，也不确定我是怎么失去他的。
As a kid and as the oldest of four brothers, I believed in Santa Claus way past the point of healthy. I was a fanatic. At the slightest provocation, I'd defend Santa's honor with a flurry of punches against any nay-saying elementary school punk. My fervor was pure and scary. I remembered that feeling now. And I knew one thing, I wanted it back.
小时候，作为四个兄弟中的老大，我相信圣诞老人的时间远超正常的年龄。我是一个狂热分子。稍微有一点挑衅，我就会挥舞拳头，捍卫圣诞老人的荣誉，反击任何敢于否认他的小学小混混。我的热情是纯粹而可怕的。我现在回忆起了那种感觉。而且我知道一件事，我想找回它。
It's a couple weeks before Christmas. One minute, I'm futzing with recyclables, living what constitutes a basically normal life. And the next, a plain brown package arrives at the door, a little gift I've sent myself, something I'm not sure I want the neighbors to know about. I'm 33 years old, and I bought myself a Santa suit. It's a strange moment unwrapping that box, cardboard and paper giving way to rich, red cloth and oodles of white wig hair. It stirs a feeling.
那是圣诞节前几周。前一分钟，我还在摆弄可回收物，过着基本上正常的生活。下一分钟，一个朴素的棕色包裹送到门口，那是我寄给自己的小礼物，我不太确定是否想让邻居知道这件事。我33岁了，给自己买了一套圣诞老人服装。拆开那个盒子是一个奇怪的时刻，纸板和纸张让位于华丽的红色布料和成堆的白色假发。它激起了一种感觉。
You really can't explain something like this to the people in your life. What? You're going to infiltrate the Santa underworld as Santa yourself in the name of proving he exists? So you don't explain. Here's what you do.
你真的无法向生活中的人解释这样的事情。什么？你要以圣诞老人的身份潜入圣诞老人的地下世界，以此来证明他的存在？所以你什么也不解释。这就是你要做的。
You stick that Santa suit in your garment bag and go. You let momentum take your body, rocket it from a tarmac, hurtle it through space like a satellite, and land it on another planet, changed, a place that looks a lot like the Pole itself.
你把那套圣诞老人服装放进你的衣物袋里，然后出发。你让冲力带着你的身体，从跑道上起飞，像卫星一样在太空中疾驰，然后降落在另一个星球上，改变了自己，那个地方看起来很像北极本身。
It's Minnesota actually, but close enough. The night before my first appearance as Claus, I take my Santa suit from the garment bag. It's a deluxe model with luxurious, deep red velvet, faux fox fur trim, blacks spats to wear over my boots, and Santa glasses with little, square, plastic lenses. To beef up my belly, there is a big cushion like a catcher's protector.
其实是明尼苏达州，但足够相似了。我第一次以克劳斯身份出现的前一天晚上，我从衣物袋里拿出我的圣诞老人服装。这是一个豪华型号，有奢华、深红色的天鹅绒，人造狐狸毛饰边，穿在靴子外面的黑色护腿，还有带有小方形塑料镜片的圣诞老人眼镜。为了填满肚子，有一个像接球手护胸一样的大垫子。
Christmas in America means a trip to the mall. And tomorrow, I'll show up at the biggest one I could find, the mall of malls, the Mall of America. I've already been given a crash course in Santa 101 by the mall star Santa. But it doesn't matter. I fall asleep with pangs of doubt. Do I have what it takes? And what the hell does it take?
美国的圣诞节意味着去购物中心旅行。明天，我将出现在我能找到的最大的购物中心，购物中心里的购物中心，美国商城。我已经接受了商场明星圣诞老人的圣诞老人101速成课程。但这并不重要。我带着怀疑的痛苦入睡。我有能力胜任吗？到底需要什么才能胜任？
Morning comes. An inauspicious start. The costume is hot and itchy, especially the wig and the beard. And until you're Santa, you never know little things about yourself, like I'm a real peripheral vision guy. I like to know who's coming at me with a blackjack. Also, I enjoy oxygen. Trapped in all that synthetic filament, I find myself gasping for air.
早晨来了。一个不祥的开始。服装又热又痒，尤其是假发和胡子。除非你当过圣诞老人，否则你永远不会了解关于你自己的小事，比如我是一个非常有余光视觉的人。我喜欢知道谁拿着棍棒向我走来。此外，我喜欢氧气。被困在所有这些合成纤维中，我发现自己喘不过气来。
Finally, and perhaps most damning, I don't like being the center of attention at all. I mumble at people, unreeling halfhearted ho, ho, hos. Attempting something more theatrical, I lift my hand and wave mechanically. "Maaa-reee Chrees-maas, everyone." It comes out as if I were just off the boat from Transylvania.
最后，也许最致命的是，我根本不喜欢成为关注的焦点。我对人们嘟囔着，半心半意地发出“吼，吼，吼”的声音。试图进行更具戏剧性的表演时，我举起手机械地挥动。“大家圣诞快乐。”听起来好像我刚从特兰西瓦尼亚乘船过来。
Moving on, I spy a group of older kids, maybe 12-year-olds, wearing baggy jeans pulled low, delinquent skateboard nihilist types. My first impulse is to try to slip by them, make it seem as if I'm window shopping. But of course, I'm not. The fact that they're looking at me requires a response. But before I've thought it through, I actually hear myself addressing their leader. "What's up, cuz?" Someone giggles. Everyone else starts backing away. A sober and depressing thought occurs to me. I make a sucky Santa.
继续走，我看到一群大一点的孩子，大约12岁，穿着低腰宽松牛仔裤，那种玩滑板的虚无主义混混。我的第一冲动是试图溜过他们，假装我在逛商店。但当然，我不是。他们看着我的事实需要一个回应。但在我仔细思考之前，我竟然听到自己在对他们的领头人说话。“怎么了，老兄？”有人咯咯笑。其他人开始退后。一个清醒而令人沮丧的想法出现在我脑海中。我是一个糟糕的圣诞老人。
Even if I have been a disservice to Christmas, my failure drives me forth. Out of curiosity and secret shame, out of righteousness and mad purpose, I take to the sky in the spirit of Claus and make house calls. In New York, I ride a bus along Fifth Avenue with 50 volunteer street corner Kringles on our way to a Santa parade. "You got to get down with the people," one of them, a man named Socrates, tells me. "You got to jing-a-ling for the cha-ching."
即使我对圣诞节造成了损害，我的失败也驱使我前行。出于好奇和秘密的羞愧，出于正义感和疯狂的目的，我以克劳斯的精神飞向天空，进行家访。在纽约，我乘坐第五大道的一辆公交车，和50名志愿者克林格尔一起去参加圣诞老人游行。“你必须和人们打成一片，”其中一个名叫苏格拉底的男人告诉我。“你必须为了钱而发出叮当声。”
In California, I lay a wreath on the grave of the great Jewish Santa, Herman Epstein. He would eat his latkes and matzah balls and then suit up as Big Red to visit sick kids at a local hospital. He did it for 50 years. And then in Redmond, Washington, I go to Microsoft headquarters dressed as Santa just to see. I camp myself on a corner, and a Mercedes sedan pulls up. A middle-aged man leaps out, piping mad. He's a Microsoft public relations person. He points at me, Santa, and sputters, "I am god damn sick of your guerrilla tactics," as if life at Microsoft is a constant parade of angry trolls and elves.
在加利福尼亚，我在伟大的犹太圣诞老人赫尔曼·爱泼斯坦的墓前献上花圈。他会吃他的煎土豆饼和圆面包，然后穿上大红衣去当地医院探望生病的孩子。他坚持了50年。然后在华盛顿州雷德蒙德，我打扮成圣诞老人去微软总部，只是为了看看。我把自己驻扎在一个角落里，一辆梅赛德斯轿车停了下来。一个中年男子跳了出来，气急败坏。他是微软的公关人员。他指着我，圣诞老人，气喘吁吁地说：“我他妈的受够了你们的游击战术，”仿佛微软的生活是一场不断的愤怒巨魔和精灵的游行。
I have a friend in Los Angeles named David Punch. And when he hears what I'm up to, he decides to join me. He instantly comes up with a green felt elf costume with impressive knee-high candy cane socks and a cap that makes him look a bit like a Danish sous chef. He's an unusual elf at six foot, three inches, but he too wants to believe. Santa christens him Fancy, and we take to the streets with no particular plan.
我在洛杉矶有一个朋友叫大卫·潘奇。当他听到我的所作所为时，他决定加入我。他立刻想出了一套绿色的毛毡精灵服装，配上令人印象深刻的及膝糖果手杖袜，还有一顶让他看起来有点像丹麦厨师助手的帽子。作为一个6英尺3英寸的人，他是一个不同寻常的精灵，但他也很想相信。圣诞老人给他取名叫“时髦”，我们没有特别计划就上了街。
We get in a rental car and track the planes to LAX at sunset, then decide to meet and greet the hordes as they arrive from Asia and Africa. Even if Santa is in decline here in America, he's still big-time abroad and growing in places where you would least expect it. In baggage claim, I'm received like a celebrity. A flight from Taiwan, they pat my stomach wide-eyed, and so I share a good belly laugh with them. A flight from Egypt, they want to touch my impressive beard. A flight from Sierra Leone, they want pictures with their extended families.
我们坐进一辆租来的车，在日落时分追踪飞机去洛杉矶国际机场，然后决定去迎接从亚洲和非洲赶来的大批人群。即使圣诞老人在美国处于衰落状态，他在国外依然大受欢迎，并且在一些你最意想不到的地方还在增长。在行李提取处，我像名人一样受到欢迎。一架从台湾来的航班，他们瞪大眼睛拍着我的肚子，于是我和他们一起开怀大笑。一架从埃及来的航班，他们想摸我那令人印象深刻的胡子。一架从塞拉利昂来的航班，他们想和大家庭一起拍照。
When I wander outside, a cab driver pulls over and rolls down his window. "Hello, my friend Mr. Claus," he says, gesturing for me to come over. "Hello, yes, you are American?" I tell him, "Yes. But, ho, ho, ho. I'm also a citizen of all nations. And I live at the North Pole." "Yes, a citizen," he says. But he is oddly intense and emotional. And though he knows I'm not looking for a ride, he has pulled his banged-up car on the curb to-- to what? Say hello to Santa Claus?
当我走到外面时，一名出租车司机停下车，摇下窗户。“你好，我的朋友克劳斯先生，”他说，示意我过去。“你好，是的，你是美国人吗？”我告诉他，“是的。但是，吼，吼，吼。我也是各国公民。我住在北极。”“是的，公民，”他说。但他显得异常紧张和激动。虽然他知道我不是要搭车，但他还是把那辆破旧的车停在路边，为了——为了什么？和圣诞老人打个招呼？
Yesterday, I was a refugee from Afghanistan. And today, I am a citizen too. He reaches into his glove compartment and pulls out a fresh envelope. "My papers, Mr. Claus. I'm an American like you." He smiles, eyes watering and grabs my hand. "Merry Christmas, Mr. Claus," he says. And then suddenly, he's gone, two more taillights lost in the sea of traffic.
昨天，我还是来自阿富汗的难民。今天，我也是一名公民。他伸手进手套箱，拿出一个崭新的信封。“我的证件，克劳斯先生。我和你一样是美国人。”他微笑着，眼里含着泪水，抓住我的手。“圣诞快乐，克劳斯先生，”他说。然后突然之间，他走了，两个尾灯消失在车海中。
Fancy and I hit the road, headed east toward Vegas into the desert, driving with several bag lunches because Santa's appetite has become insatiable. Gassing up in Barstow, I chat with a nice fellow in a cowboy hat at the self-serve, quiz him about the local color in these high desert parts. "You like drinking?" "There are really only bars in Barstow," he says, "and I don't recommend them unless you feel like getting beat up." Still, there's something about the look of this place, the weird metallic taste of it in the air, the dead-endedness of it.
“时髦”和我上了路，向东前往拉斯维加斯，进入沙漠，带着几个盒装午餐开车，因为圣诞老人的胃口变得贪得无厌。在巴斯托加油时，我和自助加油站里一个戴牛仔帽的友好家伙聊天，向他打听这些高沙漠地区的当地风情。“你喜欢喝酒吗？”“巴斯托真的只有酒吧，”他说，“除非你想挨揍，否则我不推荐你去。”不过，这个地方的样子、空气中奇怪的金属味、死胡同般的感觉，确实有些特别。
So we take a drive around, me in my red cap, Fancy in his pointy hat, and happen upon a four-corner with a cement structure and neon beer signs lit in the windows, one of those promised rough and tumble bars of Barstow. It's a bleak, Santa-less place. Inside are a couple of pool tables, a dartboard, and a long row of weathered-looking, tattooed human beings, still parched after guzzling an afternoon's worth of drinks. As Santa bellies up to the bar, everyone stares, including the bartender, who says, "What do you need?" "I'll have what he's having," Santa says, pointing to the first broken-down hombre to his left, "and he'll have another." Suddenly, everybody wants something, tequila or whiskey shots, a pack of cigarettes, and Santa flutters more bills at the bartender.
于是我们开车四处转转，我戴着红帽子，“时髦”戴着尖帽子，偶然发现了一个四角路口，那里有一个水泥结构和霓虹灯招牌在窗户里闪烁，是那些巴斯托所谓的粗犷酒吧之一。这是一个荒凉的、没有圣诞老人的地方。里面有几张台球桌、一个飞镖盘和一排排风吹日晒、纹着身的人，他们在喝了一下午酒后依然口干舌燥。当圣诞老人大步走到吧台前时，每个人都盯着看，包括酒保，他问道：“你需要什么？”“他喝什么我就喝什么，”圣诞老人指着左边第一个落魄的家伙说，“再给他来一杯。”突然，每个人都想要点什么，龙舌兰酒或威士忌，一包烟，圣诞老人向酒保又扔了几张钞票。
"There's nothing rough-and-tumble about it at all," thinks Santa. But just as that thought arrives, a voice slurs over Santa's left shoulder. "Who the [BLEEP] are you?" When I turn around, I'm standing nose to nose with a man wearing a camouflage jacket. Long, stringy hair falls from his baseball cap. His knuckles are dirty and scabbed. His breath smells of mash and lighter fluid. His smile is lopsided, not friendly, but menacing.
“这里根本没什么粗犷的，”圣诞老人想。但就在那个想法浮现时，一个声音在圣诞老人的左肩后含糊不清地响起。“你他妈的是谁？”当我转过身时，我和一个穿着迷彩夹克的男人鼻尖对鼻尖。长长的、乱糟糟的头发从他的棒球帽下垂下来。他的指关节又脏又结痂。他的呼吸里带着麦芽酒和打火机的味道。他的微笑是歪斜的，不友好，但带有威胁性。
"Who the holy freaking [BLEEP] are you?" He says again. It's a fair question, one that maybe should have occurred to me before now, before I came in here looking as I look, in red coat and fake, hoary beard. Or, for that matter, before barnstorming the country in search of something that is nearly impossible to explain and perhaps more impossible to find, but boils down to a simple belief in, well, Santa. But then there doesn't seem to be a lot of him here at the booze-hole. My answer is automatic and uncensored. "I'm Santa Claus," I say, "and who the [BLEEP] are you?"
“你他妈的到底是谁？”他又说了一遍。这是一个公平的问题，也许在我来这里之前，在我以现在的样子——穿着红外套，戴着虚假的、灰白的胡子——出现在这里之前，就该想到的。或者，在那之前，在全国范围内寻找一种几乎不可能解释、也许更不可能找到的东西，但归根结底就是对，嗯，圣诞老人的简单信仰。但在这个酒窝里似乎并没有多少他的身影。我的回答是自动的、未经审查的。“我是圣诞老人，”我说，“那你他妈的又是谁？”
There is stunned silence at the bar until somebody snorts. Someone else guffaws. And then, like a wave crashing and unfurling along a shoreline, there's hooting, and hollering, and laughing that passes down the length of the entire bar. "You hear that, boys? Santa's about to rip Billy a new [BLEEP] hole." The distraction confuses my new friend.
吧台里陷入了死一般的沉默，直到有人哼了一声。另一个人发出大笑。然后，就像海浪在海岸线上冲击和翻滚一样，整条吧台爆发出一阵嘘声、欢呼声和笑声。“你听到了吗，伙计们？圣诞老人要给比利开个新屁眼。”这种干扰让他困惑。
"His name's Billy Budd, and he ain't going to touch you," says a kind-looking man with a Van Dyke and a cigarette who has abruptly stepped between us. "Because if he does, I'm going to run his head through that window, right Billy?" "Oh yeah, Donald," Billy says with a sudden smile. Billy Budd is drunk and perhaps just bipolar enough to immediately forget that we were in the middle of a conversation full of passion and unanswered queries.
“他的名字叫比利·巴德，他不会碰你的，”一个留着凡戴克胡子、抽着烟、突然走到我们中间的慈眉善目的男人说。“因为如果他敢，我就要把他的头塞进那扇窗户，对比利，对吧？”“哦，是的，唐纳德，”比利突然笑着说。比利·巴德喝醉了，也许有点双相情感障碍，以至于立刻忘了我们刚才还在进行一场充满激情和未解疑问的对话。
And now we're suddenly chatting, Billy, Donald, and I. They're both homeless. Billy Budd counts himself as an anarchist. And they sell crystals.
现在我们突然聊开了，比利、唐纳德和我。他们两个都无家可归。比利·巴德自称是无政府主义者。他们兜售水晶。
I buy them a couple beers. And in return, they give me a crystal, a special Brazilian one with amazing properties meant to protect me against evil and bring light into my world. When I insist on paying for it, Billy Budd says, "Your money's no good with us, man. When you're with us, you're a brother." It's Santa's first gift.
我给他们买了几杯啤酒。作为回报，他们给了我一颗水晶，一颗带有神奇属性的特殊巴西水晶，旨在保护我免受邪恶侵害，并为我的世界带来光明。当我坚持要付钱时，比利·巴德说：“伙计，你的钱在我们这儿不管用。当你和我们在一起时，你就是兄弟。”这是圣诞老人收到的第一份礼物。
"What do you want for Christmas?" I say to Billy Budd. We're standing nose to nose again. It seems that's the way Billy Budd likes it. "If I tell you, are you going to give it to me?" "Yeah, I am. I'm Santa Claus, right?" "Anything?" "Anything at all." He ponders, begins to speak, stops. "Yeah, I reckon we could use a few cases of Natural Ice."
“圣诞节你想要什么？”我问比利·巴德。我们又一次鼻尖对鼻尖。看来比利·巴德就喜欢这样。“如果我告诉你，你会给我吗？”“会的，我会的。我是圣诞老人，对吧？”“任何东西？”“任何东西。”他思考着，开始说话，又停了下来。“是的，我想我们需要几箱Natural Ice啤酒。”
So I go with them and another one of their friends-- a man who looks just like Santa too, but without the outfit-- to buy beer. Afterward, we drive up to their encampment on a ridge north of town, just some sleeping bags and empty beer cans and the embers of a fire flickering in the desert, somewhere that seems utterly nowhere. Billy Budd presses a can into my hand. "Here you go, Santa." Together, we drink.
于是我和他们以及他们的另一个朋友——一个看起来也很像圣诞老人，但没穿那身行头的人——一起去买啤酒。之后，我们开车前往他们在城北山脊上的营地，那里只有几个睡袋、空的啤酒罐和沙漠中忽明忽暗的篝火，那是一个看起来完全虚无的地方。比利·巴德把一罐啤酒塞进我手里。“给你，圣诞老人。”我们一起喝了起来。
The air is cold, and the sky is spackled with stars, the brightest at the highest point above our heads. The beer tastes salty and good going down. And when Donald offers me a cigarette, I take it, though I don't normally smoke. When I go to light up, I nearly set my beard on fire. We talk about everything, about America, its prettiest spots, its most lowdown. We talk about home, where it is, why we're not there right now.
空气很冷，天空点缀着星星，最亮的那颗就在我们头顶。啤酒喝下去咸咸的，感觉很好。当唐纳德递给我一支烟时，我接过来，尽管我通常不抽烟。当我点火时，差点把胡子烧着了。我们谈论一切，谈论美国，它最美的地方，最底层的地方。我们谈论家，在哪里，为什么我们现在不回家。
These men, dressed in dirty jeans and jackets, slugging Natural Ice, open up to Santa. Not to me, but to Santa. They're good people who have drawn a hard lot and then somehow have been dismissed, driven out of America to live at its forgotten edges. Not that they see it that way. No, the amazing thing is that they're standing here with pockets full of crystals. They gave Santa his first gift.
这些穿着脏牛仔裤和夹克、灌着Natural Ice啤酒的男人，向圣诞老人敞开了心扉。不是对我，而是对圣诞老人。他们是好人，命运多舛，然后不知何故被抛弃了，被赶出了美国，生活在被遗忘的边缘。并不是说他们是这样看的。不，令人惊奇的是，他们站在这里，口袋里装满了水晶。他们给了圣诞老人第一份礼物。
And now Donald is talking about God and how Christmas will probably be spent right here on this patch of sand. And it will be the holiest, most rollicking beer-swilling day of celebration they can put on. Billy Budd says, he's going to cook a turkey with stuffing. And Donald smiles at him and says, they'll give thanks to the Lord for their freedom, for all of this. Then he points up at the sky, to the North Star. "I know it don't seem like it," says Billy Budd, "but we're looking for the answers too."
现在唐纳德正在谈论上帝，谈论圣诞节可能就在这片沙地上度过。这将是他们能举办的最神圣、最喧闹的畅饮庆祝日。比利·巴德说，他要烤一只火鸡做馅。唐纳德对他微笑着说，他们会为了他们的自由，为了这一切感谢上帝。然后他指着天空，指着北极星。“我知道这看起来不像，”比利·巴德说，“但我们也在寻找答案。”
Christmas Eve, a mall somewhere in the middle of America. A grown man dressed in a red hat, and red jacket, and red pants with white fur trim. It seems he's worn his Santa robes for so long they've become comfortable. And the beard, it almost feels natural. He keeps a Brazilian crystal in his pocket. He catches a reflection of himself in a store window. Santa.
平安夜，美国中部某个商场。一个成年男人穿着红帽子、红夹克和红裤子，带有白色毛皮饰边。看起来他穿这身圣诞老人长袍太久了，以至于变得很舒适。胡子摸起来也几乎很自然了。他在口袋里放了一颗巴西水晶。他在商店橱窗里看到了自己的倒影。圣诞老人。
The people here come fast and furious. An old woman reaching out for his hand now. A teenage punk strung out on something saying, "Hey, Santa, don't forget me. OK?" A Jamaican man calls him "Papa Noel," and tells him he needs his wife back for Christmas. They come in all ages. They come to touch him, or stand nearby, or flash a picture, to confess or ask a kindness, to make it real.
这里的人群来得又快又猛。一位老妇人现在伸出手想要握住他的手。一个吸毒成瘾的少年混混说：“嘿，圣诞老人，别忘了我，好吗？”一个牙买加男人称他为“诺埃尔爸爸”，并告诉他他需要妻子回来过圣诞节。他们各个年龄段的都有。他们来触摸他，或者站在附近，或者拍照，去忏悔或请求一份善意，让这一切变得真实。
Every time he thinks he might feel tired, after all the hard work of bringing Christmas to the world, he feels energized. Somewhere near the mall fountain, just beyond the food court, humanity parts in a light-filled glade. And there are two twin brothers, clutching hands, wearing the same blue corduroy overalls, pointing at Santa in complete shock and awe. They don't know whether to run for him or run far, far away. But then it doesn't take much.
每次他觉得累了，在为世界带来圣诞节的辛苦工作后，他都会感到精力充沛。在商场喷泉附近，就在快餐店外，人群在空旷明亮处分开。有两个双胞胎兄弟，手拉着手，穿着同样的蓝色灯芯绒工作裤，完全震惊和敬畏地指着圣诞老人。他们不知道是该冲向他，还是远远跑开。但随后，一点点触动就足够了。
Santa comes down on one knee and opens his arms. And the two boys break into huge toothless grins and bust into a sprint, just leap right into Santa's arms simultaneously, one in either arm. Sometimes people wonder what it's like to be Santa, if it gets heavy carrying kids like that. But I'm here to tell you, you never felt something so light. Like birds when they lift off the ground, they don't weigh anything at all.
圣诞老人单膝跪地，张开双臂。两个男孩露出巨大的无牙笑容，开始冲刺，同时跳进圣诞老人的怀里，一边一个。有时候人们想知道当圣诞老人是什么感觉，背着孩子会不会很重。但我在这里告诉你，你从未感受到如此轻盈的东西。就像小鸟起飞时一样，他们一点重量都没有。
Mike Paterniti lives in Portland, Maine. A version of this story has appeared in Esquire magazine.
迈克·帕特尼蒂住在缅因州波特兰。这个故事的一个版本曾刊登在《君子》杂志上。
[MUSIC - "WILL SANTA COME TO SHANTY TOWN?" BY EDDY ARNOLD]
[音乐 - 艾迪·阿诺德的《圣诞老人会来棚户区吗？》]
Act Two, If This Sleigh is A-Rockin', Don't Come A-Knockin'. When the poem says that Saint Nick has a little, round belly that shook when he laughed like a bowl full of jelly, for most of us, that is about as real as we want to get when it comes to Santa getting all physical. But the makers of popular music do not respect this simple boundary. No, no, no. And in today's program, as we try to understand all the various sides of Santa, Sarah Vowell decided to explain this one.
第二幕，《如果这雪橇在摇晃，别来敲门》。当那首诗说圣尼克有一个圆圆的小肚子，笑起来像一碗果冻时，对于我们大多数人来说，这就是关于圣诞老人变得身体接触时我们所能接受的现实程度了。但流行音乐制作人并不尊重这条简单的界限。不，不，不。在今天的节目中，当我们试图理解圣诞老人的各个侧面时，萨拉·沃威尔决定解释这一面。
Even as a child, I loved Christmas songs almost as much as Christmas itself. I loved their arcane language, "round yon virgin," "feast of Stephen," verbs like "hark" and "deck." But there was one Christmas song I couldn't stand, "I Saw Mommy Kissing Santa Claus." That one made me nervous. And it made me suspicious of Santa's good intentions. I thought, if he went after someone else's mother, mine might be next.
即使在孩提时代，我喜爱圣诞歌曲的程度几乎和喜爱圣诞节本身一样。我喜欢它们深奥的语言，“圆圆的处女”、“斯蒂芬的节日”，像“倾听”、“装饰”这样的动词。但我有一首圣诞歌受不了，就是《我看见妈妈亲吻圣诞老人》。那首歌让我感到紧张。而且让我怀疑圣诞老人的好意。我想，如果他追求别人的母亲，我的母亲可能是下一个。
Yeah, what a laugh. My poor, unsuspecting father, the man who went to all that trouble setting out the milk and cookies, catches mom in the act with Father Christmas? What happens then? She ditches us, runs off to the North Pole, and my sister and I are latch key kids by New Year's Eve. I was probably 21 before I figured out that the smoocher in that song was supposed to be the dad. But still, "I Saw Mommy Kissing Santa Claus" is just one of the many gossipy, musical reports about that sexpot Saint Nick.
是的，真是个笑话。我那可怜的、毫无戒心的父亲，那个费尽心思摆放牛奶和饼干的人，抓到妈妈和圣诞老人偷情？那会发生什么？她甩了我们，跑到了北极，我和妹妹在新年前夜就成了没人管的孩子。我大概21岁时才明白那首歌里亲吻的人应该是爸爸。但即便如此，《我看见妈妈亲吻圣诞老人》也只是关于那个性感圣尼克的众多八卦音乐报道之一。
A sweep through the Santa song catalog corroborates my childhood suspicion that Santa is not just a friend to children, he is a ladies' man. December 1976 was Elvis Presley's final holiday season, but it was my first with his Christmas record. And this became my favorite Christmas song, "Santa Claus Is Back In Town."
浏览圣诞老人的歌曲目录，证实了我童年的怀疑：圣诞老人不仅仅是孩子的朋友，他还是一个女性杀手。1976年12月是埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的最后一个假日季节，但却是我和他圣诞唱片的第一个节日。于是这成了我最喜欢的圣诞歌，《圣诞老人回来了》。
[SINGING] Got no sleigh with reindeer, no sack on my back, you want to see me coming in a big, black Cadillac. Oh, it's Christmas time, pretty baby.
[唱歌] 没有驯鹿拉的雪橇，背后没口袋，你想看我开着一辆黑色的大凯迪拉克来。噢，圣诞节到了，漂亮宝贝。
I hear that song now, and I can not believe my parents gave me this as a gift on Jesus's birthday. It is filthy, which you could expect from a home wrecker like Santa. Listen to this part.
我现在听这首歌，无法相信我的父母竟然把它作为耶稣诞辰的礼物送给我。这太下流了，你可以从像圣诞老人这样的破坏家庭者身上预料到这一点。听听这一段。
[SINGING] Hang up your pretty stockings, turn off the light, Santa Claus is coming down your chimney tonight. Oh, it's Christmas time, little baby.
[唱歌] 挂好你漂亮的袜子，关上灯，圣诞老人今晚要顺着烟囱下来了。噢，圣诞节到了，小宝贝。
You think that's dirty? Get a load of Clarence Carter's song "Back Door Santa," and you'll know why Santa goes around saying, ho, ho, ho. Because he is a ho. He's less interested in little children than in their mothers.
你觉得那很下流？听听克拉伦斯·卡特的歌《后门圣诞老人》，你就知道为什么圣诞老人到处说“吼，吼，吼”了。因为他是个流氓。他对小孩的兴趣比对他们的母亲少。
[SINGING] I keep some change in my pocket in case the children at home. I give 'em a few pennies, so that we can be alone. I leave the back door open so if anybody smells a mouse. And wouldn't old Santa be in trouble if there ain't no chimney in the house? They call me back door Santa. I make my runs about the break of day. Looky here. I make all the little girls happy while the boys are out to play.
[唱歌] 我在口袋里放些零钱，以防家里有孩子。我给他们几个便士，好让我们独处。我把后门打开，以防有人闻到老鼠味。如果屋里没有烟囱，圣诞老人不就有麻烦了吗？他们叫我后门圣诞老人。我在破晓时分奔波。瞧，当男孩们出去玩时，我让所有的小姑娘都开心。
This is what happens when pop music and Christmas collide. The project of Christmas, to celebrate the birth of a messiah who will die to save our souls, is at odds with the project of pop music. The project of pop music is love, specifically, romantic love and not the for-God-so-loved-the-world kind.
这就是当流行音乐和圣诞节碰撞时发生的事情。圣诞节的项目，是为了庆祝一个为了拯救我们灵魂而死的救世主的诞生，这与流行音乐的项目格格不入。流行音乐的项目是爱，特别是浪漫的爱，而不是上帝爱世人那种爱。
If a pop musician is going to perform a Christmas song, he or she doesn't have that much to work with from a let's do it point of view. There's the infant Jesus in swaddling clothes. There's Bethlehem, that swaddling town. There's Joseph and his wife Mary, a virgin, assorted wise men and animals, and there's Santa Claus. From a getting it on perspective, you can see how the craggy, old, fat man wins by default.
如果一个流行音乐家要表演一首圣诞歌，从“做爱”的角度来看，他或她并没有太多素材可用。有在襁褓中的婴儿耶稣。有伯利恒，那个襁褓之城。有约瑟夫和他的妻子玛丽，一个处女，还有各式各样的智者和动物，然后就是圣诞老人。从“搞上”的角度来看，你可以看出那个粗鲁、肥胖的老头是如何默认胜出的。
Take Madonna. Though most famous for being named after Jesus Christ's mother, Madonna took some time out of her busy missionary schedule to cover this Eartha Kitt classic as a benefit for charity. It is not the babe Jesus she croons to, but the babe magnet, Santa.
以麦当娜为例。虽然最著名的是以耶稣基督母亲的名字命名，但麦当娜从繁忙的传教日程中抽出时间，作为慈善义演翻唱了这首艾莎·凯特的经典之作。她对着唱的不是婴儿耶稣，而是吸引女人的圣诞老人。
[SINGING] Santa baby, slip a sable under the tree for me. I've been an awful good girl, Santa baby. And hurry down the chimney tonight.
[唱歌] 圣诞宝贝，给我塞件紫貂皮草到树下。我一直是个乖女孩，圣诞宝贝。快点今晚从烟囱下来吧。
Santa's job is to fulfill a child's wishes. And it makes sense that, as a child grows up, she might wish for something a little steamier than two front teeth. A letter to Santa, then, is a blank page on which the heart writes what the heart wants. Listen, for example, to that six-foot-tall valentine, RuPaul.
圣诞老人的工作是满足孩子的愿望。孩子长大后，希望得到的东西比两颗门牙更刺激一点，这是合理的。因此，写给圣诞老人的信是一张白纸，心灵在上面写下它想要的。听听那个6英尺高的情人，鲁保罗。
[SINGING] I saw daddy kissing Santa Claus underneath the mistletoe last night.
[唱歌] 我看见爸爸昨晚在槲寄生下亲吻圣诞老人。
In all these songs, Santa does not live on the North Pole. He lives among us. Santa is us with all our flaws, flaws like lust, infidelity, and all the pleasures of the flesh. Experts no less than Cheech and Chong point out that Mrs. Claus is famous in their neighborhood for her brownies. Martin Mull does a song in which Santa is giving up dope. And here's the subtly-titled ditty, "Santa Came Home Drunk."
在所有这些歌曲中，圣诞老人并不住在北极。他生活在我们中间。圣诞老人就是我们自己，带着我们所有的缺陷，像贪婪、不忠和肉体的所有快乐这样的缺陷。权威人士切奇和钟指出，克劳斯夫人在他们社区以她的布朗尼蛋糕闻名。马丁·穆尔唱了一首歌，说圣诞老人要戒毒了。还有这首标题微妙的打油诗，《圣诞老人喝醉了回家》。
[SINGING] You talk about Santa Claus. You want to know what he's all about? Santa Claus got drunk last night. Everybody tried to throw him out. And I want to tell you, folks, how it all began. Santa stopped at a neighbor's house and started drinking good gin.
[唱歌] 你谈论圣诞老人。你想知道他到底是干什么的吗？圣诞老人昨晚喝醉了。每个人都想把他踢出去。我想告诉你们大家，这一切是怎么开始的。圣诞老人停在邻居家里，开始喝好的杜松子酒。
At some point in our lives, most of us were at least a little afraid of Santa's judgment, of that list he's checking twice, who's naughty, who's nice. What a relief to picture a Santa with all our human frailties, all our sex, and drugs, and rock and roll. A mommy-kissing chimney-comer-downer, bottle-hitting, sugar daddy Christmas.
在我们生命中的某个时刻，我们大多数人至少都有点害怕圣诞老人的审判，害怕他那张核对两次的名单，看谁调皮，谁乖巧。想象一个带着我们所有人类弱点、性欲、毒品和摇滚乐的圣诞老人，真是一种解脱。一个亲吻妈妈、从烟囱下来、嗜酒、糖爹式的圣诞节。
That's a Santa who would do well to remember the words of the birthday boy, Jesus Christ. "Thus saith the Lord, judge not that ye be not judged." And you know what they say about Jesus, don't you, Santa? He sees you when you're sleeping. He knows when you're awake. He knows when you've been bad or good. So be good for goodness sake.
那样的圣诞老人最好记住生日男孩耶稣基督的话。“主说，不要评判他人，免得你们被评判。”你知道人们是怎么说耶稣的吗，圣诞老人？他睡觉时看见你。他知道你什么时候醒着。他知道你什么时候变坏或变好。所以为了善良起见，一定要乖。
[MUSIC - "SANTA CLAUS IS COMIN' TO TOWN" BY THE JACKSON FIVE]
[音乐 - 杰克逊五人组的《圣诞老人进城了》]
Sarah Vowell lives essentially on the same block-- no kidding-- where Clement Clarke Moore, the author of the poem "'Twas the Night before Christmas," once lived on Manhattan island nearly two centuries ago. She's a columnist for the online magazine Salon. Coming up, when is Santa not Santa? Another riddle solved in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
萨拉·沃威尔住在几乎同一个街区——别开玩笑了——也就是近两个世纪前，《圣诞前夜》的作者克莱门特·克拉克·摩尔在曼哈顿岛上住过的地方。她是在线杂志《沙龙》的专栏作家。接下来，圣诞老人不是圣诞老人时是谁？国际公共广播电台将在我们节目继续时，在一分钟内为您揭开另一个谜题。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of different people to tackle that theme. Today's program, The Angels Wanna Wear My Red Suit, stories about Santa and the many different ways that we see him. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, It Takes a Nation of Santas to Hold Us Back.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种不同的人来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，《天使想穿我的红西装》，是关于圣诞老人以及我们看待他的多种不同方式的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《我们需要一个圣诞老人国家来阻挡我们》。
As we said in the first part of today's program, belief in a Santa who comes down chimneys on Christmas Eve bearing gifts is, at best as anybody can tell, something that began here in America. And so many other variations on what Santa means are also American inventions. Riz Rollins tells this story from his boyhood here in Chicago.
正如我们在节目第一部分所说，相信在平安夜通过烟囱送礼物的圣诞老人，就我们所知，是源于美国。因此，关于圣诞老人意味着什么的许多其他变体也是美国发明。里兹·罗林斯讲述了这个他童年在芝加哥的故事。
Rosie only dresses us like this when we're going somewhere really important. Even the weekly haul to church doesn't get the matching gray, flannel outfits, the ones that cause everybody to ask whether my brother and I are twins, which we adamantly are not. We wear these clothes usually only when we're going downtown. And we only go downtown when there is a local premiere of a new Disney feature, after which we might lunch at the counter of Woolworth's, co-mingling like immigrants in the new world of de facto integration.
只有在我们要去非常重要的地方时，罗西才会把我们打扮成这样。即使是每周去教堂的奔波，也不会穿上那种同款灰色法兰绒套装，那种会引起每个人问我哥哥和我是否是双胞胎的衣服，而我们绝不是。我们通常只有在去市中心时才穿这些衣服。而且我们只有在当地有迪士尼新片首映时才去市中心，之后我们可能会在伍尔沃斯的柜台吃午餐，像移民一样在事实融合的新世界里融合。
My grandmother works as a laundress in an orphanage in Chicago's North Side and makes the long trip to the city's downtown area daily. But she rarely stops there to visit a shop. She prefers to do most of her shopping on the commercial strip that crawls under the elevated train on 63rd Street on the South Side, closer to her home. It's not just that the goods and services she seeks are less expensive on the South Side. In many cases, they aren't. But commerce there wears a face that closely resembles her own.
我的祖母在芝加哥北区的一家孤儿院做洗衣工，每天都要长途跋涉到市中心。但她很少在那里停留逛商店。她更喜欢在南区63街的高架火车下爬行的商业街上购物，那里离她家更近。并不是说她寻找的商品和服务在南区更便宜。在很多情况下，并非如此。但那里的商业有一种与她自己非常相似的面孔。
Even now, after living here for over half a century, there is much of the city she has not seen. The rules of interracial decorum will never change for her. They are God-made. Each with their own kind, the Bible says. But both my brother and I are sure that the Bible is not the only word of authority in life.
即使现在，在这里生活了半个多世纪后，这座城市仍有很多地方她没见过。种族间礼仪的规则对她来说永远不会改变。它们是上帝制定的。圣经说，各从其类。但我哥哥和我确信，圣经不是生活中权威的唯一来源。
Today, as my well-dressed brother and I are led through the high stone corridors of this world by Grandma's hand, we never notice the bitter cold. We are blinded by the lights of Christmas and the season of getting. Grandma Rosie is taking us to meet the man. He has made his way from the northern land, perhaps just this day, to receive the supplications and petitions of children who have kept his precepts and awaited his graces. While we have been raised to fear the mysterious grace of God, the grace of the fat man in the red and white suit means more.
今天，当穿着整齐的哥哥和我在奶奶的带领下穿过这个世界的高石走廊时，我们从未注意到刺骨的寒冷。我们被圣诞节的灯光和收获的季节弄得眼花缭乱。罗西奶奶要带我们去见那个人。他可能就在今天从北方土地赶来，接受那些恪守他的准则、等待他恩典的孩子们的祈求和请愿。虽然我们被教导要敬畏上帝神秘的恩典，但那个身穿红白套装的胖男人的恩典对我们来说意义更大。
Children know Santa keeps residence in one place in every city. In Chicago, his cathedral is in Marshall Field's. And his holy-of-holies is somewhere on the third floor near the toys. My brother and I have been here many times before through many years. So imagine our panic as we continue walking past the first entrance of the block-long store. We say nothing, not even to each other. Perhaps Rosie is taking us on a shortcut to see the crimson saint.
孩子们知道圣诞老人住在每个城市的同一个地方。在芝加哥，他的大教堂在马歇尔菲尔德百货。他的圣所就在三楼玩具区附近。我和哥哥多年来无数次来过这里。所以想象一下，当我们继续走过那座占据整个街区的商店的第一个入口时，我们的恐慌。我们什么也没说，甚至连对方都没说。也许罗西正带我们走捷径去见那位深红色的圣人。
We maintain silence until we stand at the end of the street beyond the last entrance to Marshall Field's. This is our last chance to make our desires plain. "I thought you were going to take us to see Santa Claus," I blurt out in desperation. My grandmother replies with unbelievable patience considering the stakes of her mistake, "We are, but this year we're going to a different place." My brother and I can not conceive of Santa at a different place, for even we know that there isn't any store downtown or anywhere else that matches the commercial grandeur or Marshall Field's. So where else would Santa want to be?
我们保持沉默，直到我们站在马歇尔菲尔德最后一个入口之外的街尽头。这是我们表达愿望的最后机会。“我还以为你要带我们去见圣诞老人，”我绝望地脱口而出。祖母带着考虑到她犯错后果而令人难以置信的耐心回答道：“我们是去见他，但今年我们要去一个不同的地方。”我和哥哥无法想象圣诞老人在别处，因为即使是我们也知道，没有哪家市中心的商店或其他地方能比得上马歇尔菲尔德的商业辉煌。那么圣诞老人还会想去哪儿呢？
We pass the various stores along the main downtown shopping strip, disheartened with each passing block. We bypass Carson's, then Montgomery Ward, then smaller shops and boutiques further away from the expensive deities, closer to the affordable ones. At this rate, we'll be lucky if we see any elves or reindeer poo.
我们经过市中心主购物街沿线的各种商店，每一段路都感到失望。我们绕过了卡森百货，绕过了蒙哥马利沃德，然后是离昂贵的偶像更远、离负担得起的偶像更近的较小的商店和精品店。照这样下去，如果我们能看到任何精灵或驯鹿粪便，我们就走运了。
Finally, we stop at our destination, Sears, Roebuck and Company. This is where Grandma intends us to have an audience with the king of dreams? We stand shivering with horror at the obvious heresy. "This is where Santa is this year," Rosie postulates confidently. She is full of adult authority. And we know that we should take what she says with the same faith as we do all her other gospel. But how can we? She has never been so obviously mistaken in all the time I've known her.
最后，我们停在了目的地，西尔斯百货。这就是奶奶打算让我们觐见梦想之王的地方？我们站在那，对显而易见的异端感到颤抖。“圣诞老人今年就在这，”罗西自信地断言。她充满了成年人的权威。我们知道我们应该像对待她所有福音一样，以同样的信念接受她的话。但我们怎么能呢？在我认识她以来的所有时间里，她从未如此明显地弄错过。
We enter Sears through two large doors, rather than the perpetually revolving doors of Marshall Field's. We march up a stairwell, rather than ascending by escalator or elevator. And towards the back, next to a section of toys that have their source in the pages of Sears catalog, rather than in the frigid magic of the North Pole, sits my grandmother's version of Santa.
我们走进西尔斯的两扇大门，而不是马歇尔菲尔德那不停旋转的门。我们沿着楼梯走上去，而不是乘坐自动扶梯或电梯。在后面，就在西尔斯目录页中那些玩具的旁边，而不是在北极的寒冷魔法中，坐着祖母版的圣诞老人。
His throne is not raised like the throne of the Santa we have come to believe in. It's mundane and accessible. There is no line of acolytes waiting to petition Santa. There's no promise, or grandeur, or terror. In fact, it is as plain to me as the nose on my face that the man in loose-fitting, red and white uniform is the biggest impostor that I've ever had the chance to lay eyes on. For the man underneath the fake, silver beard is black like me.
他的王座不像我们开始相信的圣诞老人的王座那样升高。它是平庸且平易近人的。没有一排追随者在排队向圣诞老人请愿。没有承诺、辉煌或恐怖。事实上，对我来说，显而易见的是，那个穿着宽松红白制服的男人是我所见过的最大的骗子。因为那虚假的银胡子下面的男人，和我一样是黑人。
My grandmother had not prepared us to expect this change in Santa's ethnicity. Most likely, she was trying to provide a vision of goodness that resembled us. Maybe she was secretly tired of relying on the white Jesus, watching her children gyrate to their white Elvis, losing sleep waiting for white Santa. But what she did not know was that until that day I hadn't noticed any difference between black and white people. I'm sure that we had seen white people before, but usually from afar. Santa was the only white man we had a personal relationship with.
祖母并没有让我们准备好面对圣诞老人种族上的这种改变。最有可能的是，她是想提供一个与我们相似的善良愿景。也许她私下里厌倦了依赖白人耶稣，看着她的孩子们随着白人猫王扭动身体，熬夜等待白人圣诞老人。但她不知道的是，直到那天，我还没注意到黑人和白人之间有什么区别。我敢肯定我们以前见过白人，但通常是从远处。圣诞老人是我们唯一有个人关系的白人。
That day, my brother and I silently agreed to let the ruse continue. I remember half-hoping even if this man wasn't Santa that perhaps he had connections to someone who might know Santa. But unknown to me, or my brother, or Grandma Rosie, was the fact that now the lid was off the box that held the knots and confusions I'd wrestle with for the next 20 years. Nothing would be safe from doubt, no benevolence, sincerity, or article of faith. For the first time, I saw things are not what they appear. And I thus began to search for the little lies behind every truth. And I learned that every gift is purchased with sweat, and tears, and sacrifice.
那天，我和哥哥默契地同意让这个骗局继续下去。我记得甚至有一半希望，即使这个人不是圣诞老人，也许他和某位认识圣诞老人的人有联系。但我、我哥哥或罗西奶奶都不知道，当时那个装满我未来20年都要与之搏斗的结和困惑的盒子，盖子已经被掀开了。没有什么能免于怀疑，没有仁慈、真诚或信仰。第一次，我看到事物并非它们看起来的那样。我因此开始寻找每个真理背后的谎言。而且我了解到每一份礼物都是用汗水、泪水和牺牲换来的。
Riz Rollins is a DJ and writer in Seattle.
里兹·罗林斯是西雅图的一名DJ和作家。
Act Four, Santa in Handcuffs, Prometheus in Chains. What if someone actually did patrol the department store Santas for the forces of good? You know what? We do not even need to speculate about what would happen. Because right now, right at this moment, we can bring you a brand new episode of a very old radio serial that answers this very question.
第四幕，《戴手铐的圣诞老人，锁链中的普罗米修斯》。如果真的有人为了善的力量去巡逻商场圣诞老人会怎样？你知道吗？我们甚至不需要推测会发生什么。因为就在现在，就在这一刻，我们可以为您带来一部非常古老的广播连续剧的全新一集，它就回答了这个问题。
And now another exciting episode in the life of The Most Fantastic Crimefighter The World Has Ever Known. Chickenman.
现在是世界上有史以来最出色的犯罪斗士生活中的另一个激动人心的故事。鸡人。
He's everywhere. He's everywhere.
他无处不在。他无处不在。
And Santa Claus, I want a Tiffany doll. Not the Tiffany doll that wets herself. The Tiffany doll that is a nightclub singer.
还有圣诞老人，我想要一个蒂芙尼娃娃。不是那个会尿湿自己的蒂芙尼娃娃。是那个夜总会歌手的蒂芙尼娃娃。
Ho, ho, ho, ho. Well, if you're a good little girl, Santa will see what he can do.
吼，吼，吼，吼。好吧，如果你是个乖女孩，圣诞老人会看看他能做什么。
Are you really Santa Claus?
你是真的圣诞老人吗？
Well, of course I am.
嗯，我当然是。
Halt, vicious criminal impostor. I'm arresting you for being a vicious criminal impostor.
住手，邪恶的罪犯冒名顶替者。我以你是邪恶罪犯冒名顶替者的罪名逮捕你。
Hey, bird-face, who do you think you are?
嘿，鸟脸，你以为你是谁？
Who do you think you are?
你以为你是谁？
I know who I am. I'm the manager of this department store.
我知道我是谁。我是这家百货公司的经理。
Oh. Well, I am the wonderful, white-winged warrior, Chickenman, fighter of crime and/or evil, defender of those who are undefendable. That doesn't sound right.
噢。嗯，我是精彩的、长着白色翅膀的战士，鸡人，犯罪和/或邪恶的斗士，那些无法辩护之人的捍卫者。听起来不太对劲。
Oh, don't I look impressed? You can not come into this department store and arrest our Santa.
噢，你看我印象深刻吗？你不能闯进这家百货公司逮捕我们的圣诞老人。
Well, your Santa is not a real Santa. And he fibbed his fat face off to that little girl.
好吧，你的圣诞老人不是真的圣诞老人。而且他对着那个小女孩说了谎，撒了弥天大谎。
How do you know he's not Santa?
你怎么知道他不是圣诞老人？
Because I can pull on this phony beard, and it will come right off. Boy, it's really glued on tight.
因为我可以拉掉这个假胡子，它马上就会掉下来。天哪，它粘得真紧。
Oh, will you stop, you silly goose?
噢，你这只傻鹅，能停下来吗？
Actually, I'm a chicken.
其实，我是一只鸡。
The beard will not come off because it's a real beard.
胡子不会掉下来，因为那是真的胡子。
Winged warrior, what's going on here?
长翅膀的战士，这里发生什么事了？
Commissioner Norton, what are you doing here?
诺顿局长，你怎么会在这？
I am waiting to see Santa.
我在等圣诞老人。
Oh, don't be a dope. You've been duped, dope.
噢，别傻了。你被骗了，傻瓜。
All right, Commissioner. Thank you for apprehending a major threat to the holiday dreams of our children, not to mention the American way of life.
好了，局长。感谢你逮捕了一个对我们孩子节日梦想的重大威胁，更不用说对美国生活方式的威胁了。
Thank you, Officer--
谢谢你，警官——
It's Kowalski. And I'm talking about you, bird-brain.
我是科瓦尔斯基。我说的是你，鸟脑。
Moi? The wonderful, white-winged warrior, defender of the defensible? Still doesn't sound right.
我？那个精彩的、长着白色翅膀的战士，可辩护之人的捍卫者？听起来还是不太对劲。
This is the 17th Santa Claus you've arrested, including his honor, the mayor, who was playing Santa at the Midland City Community Center Christmas party for underprivileged politicians.
这是你逮捕的第17个圣诞老人了，包括市长大人，他当时正在米德兰市社区中心的圣诞派对上为贫困的政客们扮演圣诞老人。
He was an impostor. Oh, how nice, a gift of matching bracelets for the holidays.
他是个冒名顶替者。噢，多好啊，一份节日礼物，配套的手镯。
I think they're called handcuffs, winged warrior.
我想那叫手铐，长翅膀的战士。
Hold everything. The commissioner of police will vouch for me. Go ahead, sir.
等等。警察局长会为我担保。继续吧，先生。
I've never seen this chicken before in my life. How long before I can see Santa?
我这辈子从来没见过这只鸡。还要等多久我才能见到圣诞老人？
Oh, for crying out loud. I'm allowed one phone call, am I not?
噢，天哪。我有一个电话权，不是吗？
All right. But make it fast, feather-face.
好吧。但动作快点，羽毛脸。
My phone is in my beak. It will just take a second. 555-876-5436-8907.
我的电话就在我的喙里。只要一秒钟。555-876-5436-8907。
Mayor's office.
市长办公室。
Miss Manley? It's me, the winged warrior, defender of--
曼利小姐？是我，长着翅膀的战士，那个——的捍卫者。
Yeah, what do you want this time?
是的，这次你想要什么？
Well, I've gotten myself into a little trouble here by apprehending all the Santa Clauses in town, including his honor, the mayor.
嗯，我因为逮捕了城里所有的圣诞老人，包括市长大人，在这里惹了一点麻烦。
I heard about that. And I will be forever in your debt because he is such a noodge.
我听说这件事了。而且我会永远感激你，因为他真是个讨厌鬼。
Good. And I need someone from the mayor's office to vouch for me, since the Commissioner is here, and he won't.
好。我需要市长办公室的人为我担保，因为局长在这里，而他不肯。
Well, I do not vouch, honey, during the holiday season. I am too busy dreaming of a white Christmas, walking in a winter wonderland, and getting my chestnuts to roast by the open fire.
嗯，我在节日期间不担保，亲爱的。我正忙着梦想一个白色圣诞节，漫步在冬日仙境，让我的栗子在壁炉边烘烤。
Oh, well, I'm sorry to have troubled you.
噢，好吧，很抱歉打扰你了。
Well, I have to leave now, officer. I have to find a Santa chicken-puss, here, hasn't arrested.
好吧，我要走了，警官。我得去寻找一个鸡脑袋还没逮捕的圣诞老人。
What about me, commissioner?
那我呢，局长？
I never saw you before in my life.
我这辈子从来没见过你。
Well, if the commissioner doesn't recognize the winged warrior and Miss Manley is busy roasting chestnuts by an open fire, pray tell, what will happen to our hero?
好吧，如果局长不认识这位长着翅膀的战士，而曼利小姐又忙着在壁炉边烘烤栗子，请告诉我，我们的英雄会怎样？
Thank you. At least someone cares what--
谢谢。至少有人在乎——
Not you. I mean the one in the red suit with the big belly that shakes like a bowl full of jelly.
不是你。我是指那个穿着红西装、肚子像果冻碗一样晃动的家伙。
Oh, I hope the jail holiday meal isn't chicken.
噢，我希望监狱的节日餐不是鸡肉。
This has been another exciting episode in the life of The Most Fantastic Crimefighter The World Has Ever Known. Chickenman.
这就是世界上有史以来最出色的犯罪斗士生活中的另一个激动人心的故事。鸡人。
He's everywhere. He's everywhere.
他无处不在。他无处不在。
That episode of Chickenman was written and produced for our program at the Radio Ranch in Los Angeles by Christine Coyle and Dick Orkin. It featured the voices of Christine Coyle, Dick Orkin, and Rod Roddy.
那一集《鸡人》是由克里斯汀·科伊尔和迪克·奥尔金为我们的节目在洛杉矶的无线电牧场编写和制作的。由克里斯汀·科伊尔、迪克·奥尔金和罗德·罗迪配音。
[MUSIC - "SOMEBODY STOLE MY SANTA CLAUS SUIT" BY THE CHRISTMAS JUG BAND, FEATURING DAN HICKS]
[音乐 - 圣诞罐头乐队的《有人偷了我的圣诞老人服装》，丹·希克斯演唱]
Act Five, Santa Claus Versus the Easter Bunny. A while back, writer David Sedaris moved to France, where he enrolled in a school to study French. He was the only American there. As he explained to an audience at City Arts and Lectures in San Francisco, the teacher could be kind of mean.
第五幕，《圣诞老人大战复活节兔子》。不久前，作家大卫·塞达瑞斯搬到了法国，在那里他报了一个学习法语的学校。他是那里唯一的美国人。正如他在旧金山城市艺术与讲座现场向观众解释的那样，老师有时会有点刻薄。
Oh, she would throw chalk at people, and stabbed someone in the eye with a pencil one day, and would hold your homework paper over your head and show everyone the mistakes that you made. So I wrote a story about her. And she read it, and I got thrown out of school.
噢，她会朝人扔粉笔，有一天用铅笔刺伤了一个人的眼睛，还会把你的家庭作业高举过头顶，向大家展示你犯的错误。所以我写了一个关于她的故事。她读了，我就被学校开除了。
This is another story about her, and about the big religious holidays, and the sheer arbitrariness of the way we celebrate sometimes. Easter eggs, Santa filling the stockings, all the non-religious icons.
这是另一个关于她的故事，关于各大宗教节日，以及我们庆祝时那种纯粹的随意性。复活节彩蛋、往袜子里塞礼物的圣诞老人，所有这些非宗教图标。
Printed in our textbooks was a brief list of major holidays alongside a scattered arrangement of photos capturing French people in the act of celebration. The object was to match the holiday with the corresponding picture. Today's discussion was dominated by a Russian nanny, two chatty Poles, and a pouty, plump Moroccan woman who had grown up speaking French and had enrolled in the class hoping to improve her spelling.
我们的教科书里印有一份主要节日清单，旁边是一系列分散的照片，捕捉了法国人庆祝的情景。任务是把节日和相应的图片对应起来。今天的讨论主要由一位俄罗斯保姆、两名喋喋不休的波兰人，以及一位嘟着嘴、丰满的摩洛哥妇女主导，她从小就说法语，报这个班是为了提高拼写水平。
She had covered these lessons back in the third grade, and took every opportunity to demonstrate her superiority. She had recently transferred to the class. And we could not wait until she was booted up to her appropriate level. Midway through the first day, she had raised her hand so many times her shoulder had given out. Now she just leaned back in her seat and shouted the answers, her bronzed arms folded across her chest like some great grammar genie.
她在三年级时就学过这些课程，并抓住每一个机会展示她的优越感。她最近转到了这个班。我们都等不及她升到合适的水平了。第一天过半，她举手的次数多到肩膀都酸了。现在她只是靠在座位上大喊答案，那双古铜色的手臂像某种伟大的语法精灵一样叠在胸前。
We had finished discussing New Year's Eve, and the teacher had moved on to Easter, which was represented in our textbook by a black and white photograph of a chocolate bell lying upon a bed of palm fronds. "And what does one do on Easter? Would anyone like to tell us?" It was, for me, another one of those holidays I'd just as soon avoid.
我们讨论完了新年前夜，老师转到了复活节，书本上用一张躺在棕榈叶床上的巧克力钟的黑白照片来代表它。“那么复活节人们做些什么呢？有人想告诉我们吗？”对我来说，这是另一个我想避开的节日。
Growing up, my family had generally ignored the Easter celebrated by our non-Orthodox friends and neighbors, leading to the suspicion that we might be either Jews or Communists. As Greeks, we had our own Easter which was usually observed anywhere from two to four weeks after what was known in our circle as "the American version." The reason had to do with the moon or the Orthodox calendar, something mysterious like that. Though our mother always suspected it was scheduled at a later date so that the Greeks could buy their marshmallow chicks and plastic grass at drastically reduced sale prices. "The cheap sons of bitches," she'd say, "If they had their way, we'd be celebrating Christmas in the middle of god damn February."
小时候，我的家庭通常忽视非东正教朋友和邻居庆祝的复活节，导致人们怀疑我们可能是犹太人或共产主义者。作为希腊人，我们有自己的复活节，通常在我们圈子里所谓的“美国版”之后两到四周观察。原因与月亮或东正教历法有关，像那样神秘的东西。尽管我们的母亲总是怀疑它是安排在晚些时候，以便希腊人能以大幅降价购买他们的棉花糖小鸡和塑料草。“那些廉价的狗娘养的，”她说，“如果让他们说了算，我们可能要在二月中旬庆祝圣诞节了。”
A brave Italian was attempting to answer the teacher's latest question, when the Moroccan student interrupted, shouting, "Excuse me, but what's an Easter?" Despite having grown up in a Muslim country, it seems she might have heard it mentioned once or twice, but no. "I mean it," she said, "I have no idea what you people are talking about." The teacher then called upon the rest of us to explain. The Poles led the charge to the best of their ability.
一位勇敢的意大利人正试图回答老师的最新问题，摩洛哥学生打断道，大喊：“不好意思，什么是复活节？”尽管在穆斯林国家长大，但她似乎听说过一两次，但也仅此而已。“我是说真的，”她说，“我根本不知道你们在说什么。”老师于是叫我们其余的人来解释。波兰人尽其所能带头。
"It is," said one, "a party for the little boy of God who call hisself Jesus and-- you know, like that." She faltered, and her fellow countrymen came to her aid. "He call hisself Jesus, and then he die one day on two morsels of lumber."
“它，”其中一个说，“是为上帝的小男孩举办的派对，他自称是耶稣——你知道，诸如此类。”她结结巴巴，她的同胞前来帮助。“他自称是耶稣，然后有一天死在了两块木头上。”
The rest of the class jumped in, offering bits of information that would have given the Pope an aneurysm. "He die one day. And then he go above of my head to live with your father." "He weared the long hair. And after he died the first day, he come back here for to say hello to the peoples." "He nice. He make the good thing. And on the Easter, we be sad, because someone made him dead today."
班上其他人跳出来，提供了会让教皇动脉瘤发作的信息。“他死了一天。然后他去了我的头顶上方，和你父亲住在一起。”“他留着长发。在他死后的第一天，他回到了这里，为了和人民说声你好。”“他很好。他做了好事。在复活节，我们感到难过，因为今天有人让他死了。”
Part of the problem had to do with grammar. Simple nouns, such as "cross" and "Resurrection," were beyond our grasp, let alone such complicated reflexive verbs as "to give of yourself your only begotten son." Faced with the challenge of explaining the cornerstone of Christianity, we did what any self-respecting group of people might do. We talked about food instead.
部分问题与语法有关。简单的名词，如“十字架”和“复活”，超出了我们的掌握，更不用说像“舍弃你唯一的独生子”这样复杂的反身动词了。面对解释基督教基石的挑战，我们做了任何有自尊心的人可能会做的事。我们改谈食物了。
"Easter is a party for to eat of the lamb," an Italian student explained. "One, too, may eat of the chocolate." "And who brings the chocolate?" The teacher asked. I knew the word, and so I raised my hand saying, "The rabbit of Easter." "He bring of the chocolate."
“复活节是吃羊肉的派对，”一位意大利学生解释道。“人们也可以吃巧克力。”“谁带来巧克力？”老师问。我知道这个词，所以我举手说：“复活节兔子。”“他带来巧克力。”
My classmates reacted as though I had pinned the delivery on a house cat. They were mortified. A rabbit? A rabbit?
我的同学们反应得好像我把送货任务交给了家猫一样。他们感到难堪。兔子？兔子？
The teacher, assuming I had used the wrong word, positioned her index fingers on top of her head, wiggling them as though they were ears. "You mean one of these? A rabbit, rabbit?" "Well, sure," I said, "he come in the night when one sleep on a bed. With a hand, he have the basket, like for a bread."
老师以为我用错了词，把食指放在头顶，像耳朵一样摇动。“你是说这种？兔子，兔子？”“嗯，当然，”我说，“他在人们睡在床上的时候在夜里到来。他手里拿着篮子，就像面包篮一样。”
The Moroccan rolled her eyes, and the teacher sadly shook her head as if this explained everything that was wrong with my country. "No, no," she said, "here in France, the chocolate is brought by a big bell that flies in from Rome." I called for a time-out. "But how do the bell know where you live?" "Well," she said, "how does a rabbit?" It was a decent point, but at least a rabbit has eyes. That's a start.
摩洛哥人翻了个白眼，老师伤心地摇了摇头，好像这解释了我国家的一切问题。“不，不，”她说，“在法国，巧克力是由一只从罗马飞来的大钟带来的。”我要求暂停。“但钟怎么知道你住哪儿？”“嗯，”她说，“兔子又是怎么知道的？”这是一个像样的观点，但至少兔子有眼睛。那是个开始。
Rabbits move from place to place, while most bells can only go back and forth. And they can't even do that on their own power. On top of that, the Easter bunny has character. He's someone you'd like to meet. A bell has all the personality of a cast iron skillet. It's like saying that come Christmas, a magic dust pan flies in from the North Pole, led by eight flying cinder blocks.
兔子会从一个地方移动到另一个地方，而大多数钟只能来回摆动。而且它们甚至不能凭自己的力量做到这一点。除此之外，复活节兔子有性格。他是那种你想见的人。钟具有铸铁平底锅的所有个性。这就像说圣诞节时，一个魔法灰尘铲从北极飞来，由八块飞行的煤渣砖带路。
Who wants to stay up all night, so they can see a bell? And why fly one in from Rome when they've got more bells than they know what to do with right there in Paris? That's the most implausible aspect of the whole story. Because there's no way the bells of France would allow a foreign worker to fly in. There's no way the bells of France would allow a foreign worker to fly in and take their job. That Roman bell would be lucky to get work cleaning up after a French bell's dog.
谁想熬夜看钟？当巴黎有他们用不完的钟时，为什么要从罗马飞来一个？这是整个故事中最不可信的一面。因为法国的钟绝对不允许外国劳工飞进来。法国的钟绝对不允许外国劳工飞进来抢他们的工作。那只罗马钟如果能清理完一只法国钟的狗屎，就算运气好了。
And how does a bell hold the candy if it doesn't have any arms? How does it get into your house without being heard? It just didn't add up. I suppose similar questions could be asked of the Easter bunny. I had just never thought about it that hard.
如果钟没有胳膊，它怎么拿糖果？它怎么在不被听到的情况下进入你家？这完全讲不通。我想关于复活节兔子也可以提出类似的问题。我只是从来没那么认真地想过。
Nothing we said was of any help whatsoever to the Moroccan woman. Clearly disgusted, she just sat there, her lips positioned as if to spit. I wondered then if, without the language barrier, my classmates and I could have done a better job making sense of Christianity, an idea that sounds pretty far-fetched to begin with. In communicating any religious belief, the operative word is faith, a concept illustrated by our very presence in that classroom. Why bother struggling with the lessons of a six-year-old if each of us didn't believe that, against all reason, we might eventually improve? I'm not sure how that fits in with the Resurrection, but if I could hope to one day carry on a fluent conversation, it was a relatively short leap to believing that a rabbit might visit my home in the middle of the night, leaving behind a handful of chocolate kisses and a carton of menthol cigarettes. A bell though, that's [BLEEP] up.
我们说的任何话对那个摩洛哥妇女都没有任何帮助。显然很厌恶，她只是坐在那里，嘴唇摆出要吐的样子。我想那时如果没有语言障碍，我的同学们和我是否能更好地解释基督教，这个想法本身听起来就相当离谱。在交流任何宗教信仰时，关键词是信仰，这是一个通过我们在教室里的存在而阐明了的概念。如果我们每个人不相信，尽管违背一切理由，我们最终可能会有所进步，为什么要费力去学六岁孩子的课程呢？我不确定这与复活有什么关系，但如果我能希望有一天进行流畅的对话，相信一只兔子可能在深夜访问我的家，留下几颗巧克力之吻和一盒薄荷香烟，相对来说就没那么遥远了。不过钟，那真是[哔——]透了。
Here, I had spent all this time feeling intimidated by French people and for nothing. The next time the teacher humiliated me or someone at the market gave me a hard time, I'd just roll my eyes like the Moroccan woman, thinking, "Well, what can you do with a nation of people who'll apparently believe in anything?"
我在这里花了一整段时间感到被法国人吓倒，真是白费力气。下次老师羞辱我，或者市场上有人为难我时，我会像摩洛哥妇女一样翻白眼，心想：“好吧，对于一个显然什么都信的国家的人民，你能指望什么呢？”
Writer David Sedaris.
作家大卫·塞达瑞斯。
Well, our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Julie Snyder.
好了，我们的节目今天由布鲁·谢维尼和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和朱莉·斯奈德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who I would describe this way.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，我会这样形容他。
His knuckles are dirty and scabbed. His breath smells of mash and lighter fluid.
他的指关节又脏又结痂。他的呼吸里带着麦芽酒和打火机的味道。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
Not friendly, but menacing.
不友好，但带有威胁性。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。